what do you think about people who write
their personal stories
that they
they want to show themselves as a
protagonist you know a lot of people
come to la or or they're somewhere in
the midwest or wherever hey i've got
this great screenplay idea it's about my
life
is everybody ready to hear about their
life as their first project yeah you
know it's it's a difficult thing too
because the old adage is write what you
know
um and so
for beginning writers oftentimes
a
you know
autobiographical experience
is something that they know and they
they have the emotional connection to it
the the problem is you still have to
serve your audience it's got to be
entertaining
um and it's got to have enough of a
universal
appeal and i when i say that i don't
mean that means it has to be homogenized
but there has to be enough things in it
that people can connect with and
recognize behavior-wise like okay i'm
going to go with you on the story
so
whatever your story is
you've got to find a way to plug it into
more of a universal
consciousness
so that it'll it'll be
it can be absorbed by
people who don't know you don't know
your story don't care about your story
but how does your story relate to
something in my life
um i don't know if i sound very
pretentious saying all this but uh no
i don't think so you know i just think
you should never think like
my life is so fascinating that anyone
would be willing to spend two hours of
their life watching it you know
there might be great things that happen
to you
but i think you should be really willing
and able to just throw a lot of it away
and and
concentrate on the core thing
that you feel is the story you want to
tell this core thing
and then build around that make make
stuff up make it more interesting make
it make the stakes higher
bring in characters who are not real in
your life
but so you can you can build something
that might be a very good well-crafted
story
but also has enough personal resonance
uh
now for instance when i um
for many years i was doing movies for
television
and i i prided myself on
i wrote them and directed them and i i
chose very carefully what i would do i
never took a movie for the money or
because i you know i was very careful
about what i what i chose if it was a
book i want they wanted me to adapt or
oftentimes they would come to me with a
failed script
and this you know they said look we
still want to make there's an idea here
we love we want to make this movie
the script didn't work can you do
something with the script and i would
take it over and
but in any project that came to me
the first thing i had to know
was
what's my emotional connection to this
can i find one
and if i can't find it i don't want to
do it because now i can't really i don't
feel like i can make it interesting and
a case in point
is i did a movie uh back she must be 98
1988
for tnt at the time called the hunley
and it was about the first uh submarine
used uh in warfare during the civil war
fascinating story um just fascinating
but uh you know i wasn't so much into a
war movie which it was it was i wanted
to make more of a character study but i
couldn't figure out what was driving
this main character to get into this
death trap this tube
that they all had to hand crank to go
forward once they dived
you know what could this be
and i suddenly had this idea
that he was in love with a woman
um who he left to go fight the in the
war
and she died while he was gone
and she drowned
and he's now obsessed with being
reunited with her
and that's sort of his death wish now
about going into the submarine and he
feels like this is his
his
destiny in a way
and it's never spoken i never told the
executives about it god forbid because
they would think you know i'm making
some whole of the movie
but that now allowed me to inform
all the writing and this and this
character's drive through the movie
with this kind of other thing
that we revealed in just little pieces
here and there a little flashback here
or a little thing here and suddenly by
the end of the movie you start to
realize of course this is why this guy
is like this and he's driving so hard
and so that's just an example of you
know how you can take a story that's
outside yourself
um but find a personal connection that
that allows you to really
lose yourself in that story and and make
it more than what appears just you know
on the surface
how do you know when you have a movie
idea as opposed to a television idea i
don't think there's any difference now
you know that we
that that's a question i could have
answered differently back in the 80s or
90s even
now there's just no
there's there's really no difference
because of streaming
um
you know i think in fact uh i think
there's far more
more interesting work being done
uh on the streaming services than in
future films uh you know i think feature
films right now the state of the
business is
ten poll franchise gigantic movies which
seem to be the only thing people are
willing to leave their homes for
um and i think that the
you know sort of like the directors you
you think about you know mark rydell and
cindy lumet and alan pakula
those directors
would be working for the streamers today
because their movies would never be made
and no one wants to go see um
you know uh kramer vs kramer they're not
gonna they're watching it on netflix
so i mean it's sad uh of course there's
nothing like the movie experience
but i'm so grateful that the streamers
are there because they don't have to get
unlike a broadcast network you know they
got to get 15 million people to watch a
show to make it worth their while
and the streamers can be in a much
different niche and they don't have to
they've got the subscriber base
and so they can appeal they can afford
to appeal to a lot of different groups
and so um
uh
honestly most of the ideas that i get
i don't think about them as movies i
think about them as something that might
be on amazon or apple plus or netflix
not that i don't again just loves going
to the movies because i'm addicted
i mean i easily see
five or six movies a week
probably two or three in the theater
uh and then the rest on
you know plus the television shows i'm
watching you know the great you know
better call saul you know you just can't
beat the stuff it's so well done
and in a way it's very gratifying
because i think that in the era that i
came of age in television
where
you had to
they pressure you to appeal to the
lowest common denominator
and we filmmakers always said but but
you don't have to do that you know trust
the audience a little bit
and now i think that's coming to
fruition because we are now
um in the television world or the
streaming world
uh we're dealing with stories that
i would no one ever make for television
years ago would never even touch them
uh and there's an appetite for them
people show up for them they want to see
them and i think that you know again a
lot of the low brow stuff now is in the
movie theater
not not on tv
why do purpose and passion matter when
choosing a screenplay
well in a lot of different ways in the
most practical way
um
making a movie
and when i say movie i'll you know it
applies to anything you know tv movie tv
show whatever just a movie
but uh it is difficult it's hard
it's hard to get it made um if you're
lucky enough to get it made they're hard
to make
um it's it's a very very
uh difficult undertaking to make a movie
it's the greatest thing in the world
but it's hard so you must have
a high level of purpose and passion to
bring you through this because you're
gonna get
uh stepped on you're gonna you know it's
a
you're gonna you're gonna lose your
money you'll get the money back you're
gonna
here comes the rain oh no i have a good
there's so many things that happen
during the shooting and everything else
that will destroy you if you don't have
a really
good attitude and that overriding
purpose i must make this movie and this
passion for story i've got to tell this
and that passion is so key in selling
your ideas
i can't emphasize that enough if you go
to pitch a tv show or you're going to a
studio to pitch them a movie you want to
make
you have got to be genuinely passionate
about it they've got to feel that
they've got to feel like okay if we say
yes to this person
they're going to go out there and
they're going to kill themselves to make
this movie i can tell you
whereas you come in there like you're
too cool for school you know
nobody wants to hear that no you know um
and
it extends to all your collaborators
you're trying to get a certain actor
you're trying to get um you know a
certain artist to work on your film
they want to feel your passion for this
thing they want to know that you're
gonna you've got a vision and you're
gonna you're gonna get this thing done
so it's really crucial in every aspect
of the process